Wow.
Smells like doo-doo in here.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
Hello.
Welcome in.
You guys, you guys hear all the bugs?
Turn it up.
The wind is like a, it's making my ears tingle.
It's making my, it's like, it's like making my brain buzz a little bit.
It's so like, it's in my ears.
Anyway, welcome back.
Welcome to The Walking Dead.
This game is so old.
Is it?
I think it said 20.
Well, it had to be before.
Glenn.
I don't know.
You doing the buzz toys?
It's so cute.
2012.
Don't say that.
That was over 10 years ago.
2012.
If you were born in 2012, you are a child now.
Oh my god.
Wait, you'd be in like middle school.
Wait.
Wait, no, wait.
No.
children don't exist everybody children aren't real okay I'm gonna hurl stop this please sorry I'm supposed to take you out of those thoughts you'd be older than Clementine wait oh my god wait Clementine is what she said she was like eight but any chance we'll get to see our opening ghost jump from MGSCon again Jordan thank you I believe they are wanting to upload it somewhere but I haven't been told when or where but wasn't it great if you went to MGSCon or if you watched the digital stream we made a super duper awesome uh uh intro video for me oh robin they're here oh my gosh thank you yeah i got to work with robin who helped out who animated it and yeah thank you hi minto hi
we got to work with uh with uh jim as well voice of major zero so it felt it was really it was really neat the outside noises with flies makes me feel like i'm in a portable party that's why i said it was smelly this just like smells this sounds smells bad do you know what i mean major tom major
yeah it was really really awesome ramen knocked it out of the park man um but yeah that should be uploaded somewhere sometime it was my birthday yesterday thank you for always making me love and smile can i get happy birthday for my copy of the diet doctor peppy oh i see the photo want to make sure happy birthday happy birthday did you know we're now closer to 2050 than 20 than 2000 no oh i guess technically i guess technically now because it's august almost september ah it's almost september you guys
month to my birthday but I got some bad news about my birthday today so I'm kind of feeling a little down not gonna lie a lot of things have fallen through and it just feels like more and more things are falling through I'm kind of worried if I'll have anything for my birthday at all at this point yeah for this though So I was working with someone for merch in Japan,
and they're kind of worried about if they'll be able to ship to the U.S., unfortunately.
So we'll see.
Yeah.
Ah, ah, ah.
We'll have Minto.
I know, but I had a lot of stuff that I was planning and I don't want to get into it because I don't want to be sad about it again.
I don't want to be sad about it again.
But, you know, I'll do my best to still have something fun for my birthday.
Anyway.
What was I going to say?
Oh, I don't remember.
Oh, I don't remember what I was going to say.
I woke up feeling today a little...
You guys know when you...
My throat wasn't hurting, but you know when you wake up and your throat feels like swollen a little bit?
And you're like, oh no.
I think I'm getting sick.
That's how I've woke up.
And I was like, oh no!
Oh no!
I think I don't know.
Hopefully I'm not sick.
Hopefully.
Especially if you snore.
I don't snore.
I don't think I snore.
Barry didn't say that I snore.
She said that I breathed, which is also incorrect because I'm a ghost.
She probably mistook breathing or my ectoplasm, like kind of of sloshing around for for for breathing you know so yeah how dare you breathe while sleeping i don't i don't old habits die hard i guess it's hard right like i feel like i'm breathing i feel like i need to breathe but i don't because i'm dead already ask your cats they should know my cat snores and my cat sleeps next to my head and so sometimes i will hear him snoring next to me and i wake up from him snoring he kind of he goes like
that's how he snores he's such an old man my cat is like the oldest man
He's such a, he's been such a grump lately.
I had to get a, I had to get another vet appointment for him.
And I was referred to a specialist.
But the specialist was not available until October.
And I'm like, if my cat is really sick, I have to wait two months.
That's crazy.
Like, that's a really long time.
to wait my cat woke himself up by storing that's so cute uh no what it is what it is can a ghost in a zombie originate from the same body is there zombie walking around while i'm here i don't think so that would be so awkward one of us would have to change Good at celebrating your birthday with little Caesars.
We can also watch SpongeBob.
Let's go.
Big Mac!
Thank you so much for the vibe, Getsu.
Thank you.
What if I, like... Well, no.
Actually, last Halloween, I dressed up as a...
As a... A zombie.
It's kind of funny.
A ghost as a zombie.
My cat does the same.
It's like they're having a whistle next to your face.
still sleep.
My cat maybe snores too loud then.
Hopefully the cat though is okay.
Yeah, hopefully.
Hopefully, hopefully.
So a human?
The zombie's not a human.
The zombie is a zombie.
And a ghost is a ghost.
Dumb people, I mean, I'm former, former human.
Yeah.
Former human.
Ex-human.
FNAF birthday?
I always wanted to have a Chuck E.
Cheese birthday, but I couldn't.
When I was a Wee Wisp, we couldn't have a birthday at Chuck E.
Cheese because that's the place that all the gangs took over.
Excited to see you continue this game.
Let's get started.
Oh, I should have probably been on this screen, huh?
After that, I didn't think about it.
So, do I...
I just click...
Wait, episode status.
It's coming.
Coming soon.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, is this once you beat the game?
Oh, it's DLC.
Oh.
I'm not looking.
Don't ignore that.
Ignore what?
What did I...
What?
What happened?
Oh, it's a prequel.
That's exciting.
Oh my gosh, yeah.
We can just pretend it's 2012 and we're excited for the DLC that's coming out of the new Walking Dead Telltale.
games series yeah wait do I get to kill that guy that was sleeping with the wife can I pull the trigger think I just want to murder I'm ready for murder Wow there will be DLC isn't that so exciting I can't wait to play it I hope I have time after school I'm gonna get all my homework done early so I can,
uh, so I can play the new Walking Dead DLC.
He's already dead.
Okay, that's all right.
Episode two, starved for hope.
Why do they look like this?
It's kind of...
Okay.
Oh, oh, good.
We get a preview.
I know who you are.
I got another good one for you.
Okay, I called that one.
I told him to keep his eyes on the road like five times.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Stop mocking 13 year old.
What do you mean?
You keep an eye on that front door.
You're our lookout.
It's Doug.
Doug!
No!
You got it, boss.
Doug!
I should have saved you instead, Doug!
Okay, we're gonna kill that guy today.
With the bloody end of an axe handle, maybe?
Nobody threatens my boy.
Ah!
No!
Oh, Doug!
Oh, the humanity!
That's me.
And I don't give a shit about what happens to you.
But if anything happens to my...
daughter or that little girl you've got with you you watch your ass your ass is grass grandpa this game series adapts to the choices you make the story is tailored to how you play where's the ghost cafe at it's it's a secret secret location chapter 2 baby
Oh.
Get back into the swing of things.
That was a knee-slapper for...
Who that?
Who are you?
Otacon!
Good one.
It was.
That's another meal lost.
Are we eating the zombies now?
What do you mean a meal?
food in three months it seemed like so much at the time maybe you shouldn't have opened new Doug yeah except then I'd probably be food by now trust me I have no regrets rabbits hardly a meal mark but I'd take it we're all hungry zombies eat rabbits too it's rabbit hunting when I accidentally grabbed for Carly's rations the other night I thought she was gonna take off my hand we're all on edge just cut us some slack we're hungry you're right i wish i knew for sure how much food we have left oh uh wait did i play this on p oh you'll have to ask did i play this with controller before no i don't think so or mishandling it if you ask ken no no i just worried about his kid getting enough i'll worry about clementine too clementine you think kenny's having any more luck than we are out here suddenly felt bizarre i sure hope so yeah between the lack of food and kenny and Lily fighting all the time.
Things are getting pretty tense back at the motor end.
You know, Kenny's been talking about taking off if he can get that RV running.
Kenny won't abandon us.
Yeah, Kenny is good.
Kenny is a good guy.
I guess we'll see.
Can't blame him, though.
Did you hear Larry going off on him last night?
Oh, my God.
We see your guy's deal anyway.
Seems like he's got a problem with you in particular.
We gotta kill that man.
Larry?
uh I think uh he thinks I'm a danger oh wait I thought it said I thought it said the one putting us in danger he's the way I think he's dangerous I misread it I wouldn't be surprised if she's been skimming rations for him and I know Lily thinks he's getting weaker but the guy's all muscle he's a walking pile driver I know I wouldn't want to be stuck in a room with him yeah punch you in the face one time yeah knock me flat yeah he's tried to kill us he tried to murder us you get those zombies to eat us for a bird uh yeah don't risk the no wait can you make the shot it's a long shot i need to waste the bullets trust me if i don't think i can hit it i won't shoot oh okay
Oh, wow Shit, was that Kenny?
Oh, no, come on
What a weenie Great shot
Is he in a trap?
Oh, no, no, oh Jesus Christ oh no Oh, shit.
No, no.
Please don't kill us.
We just want to help our teacher.
We'll leave, I swear.
Lee, you guys okay?
Get it off.
God damn it.
Get it off me.
Oh, my God.
Travis, maybe they can help.
These might be the same guys that raided our camp, and we barely got away from that.
I think if they were, what?
Why the fuck is there a bear trap out here?
Who raided your camp?
I don't know.
Guys with guns.
Uh-oh.
Please, we won't bother you.
I swear.
Lee, this is fucked up.
We've got to help you.
Please.
Then shut up.
My dad was special forces.
I know what I'm doing.
Just see if you can get him out.
After that, you can leave us or whatever.
I don't care.
My dad was special forces.
Was he bitten?
Bitten?
No, I swear.
Uh-huh.
Uh-oh.
Hurry, please.
Hurry.
Uh-oh.
Lee, this trap's been altered.
There's no release latch.
That's evil.
What do they think the zombies are going to release themselves?
Shit, walkers.
Because now we'll never leave.
Please, get me out of this.
Uh-oh.
Get the boys back.
I don't think we should have taken the shot.
Keep those walkers off of me.
Oh, gosh.
You have to get him out.
You have to.
Hi.
Please.
Please get me out of this.
Okay, I don't know if that's going to work.
Is this going to work?
I might have chosen the wrong option.
Yeah, hurry.
It's changed like that to the Air Force base to lift ornaments.
cutting through please you can't just leave him like this what are you having oh here we go wait i'm gonna look there's gotta be something we can do really bad just get me out oh my god please save him we're gonna be surrounded any minute come on chop chop chop oh whoops i didn't mean there has to be a way out of this okay i'm sorry it has to be oh my god okay okay i got you here we go damn it lee just cut off his leg we don't have time for that no no We have to go.
Sorry,
buddy.
Oh, my God, again!
I'm doing it!
Oh, my God!
There's so many of them!
Again?
One more.
Ah!
Come up!
Shit.
You cut David free.
He passed out.
He's about to...
He's about to do way more than that.
Oh my god.
Grab him and let's go.
Free.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Okay, good.
They put a belt on it.
Behind you!
Travis!
Come on, come on.
We gotta move.
Travis.
Travis, don't turn around.
Travis, just go.
Oh, Travis.
But your dad was special voices, Travis.
What happened?
Oh, Travis.
Complete chapter one of episode two.
Going hungry.
Oh, Travis.
Aw, that guy just lost his friend you guys where's duck oh there he is being a bit of a menace
she's so bored this is what a child without tick tock looks like don't smell smile at the don't smell don't smile at that guy he sucks
Oh, I don't like the...
I don't like the...
Oh, stop it, Clementine.
You're scaring me.
Everybody's so on edge.
Get the gates open!
We've got wounded!
Shit.
What the hell are they doing?
Being good people.
What happened?
What's going on?
We don't have time to explain.
Lee, are you okay?
Get him into the truck.
I'll see what I can do.
Oh, my God.
Jesus, Ken.
I don't know.
Wait.
He just got here.
What the hell?
You can't just be bringing new people here.
What are you thinking?
Hey, you want to calm down for a fucking minute?
No, I don't.
I want to know why you thought bringing more mouths to feed was a good idea.
Oh.
He would have died if we left him.
So what?
We are not responsible for every struggling survivor we come across.
We have to focus on our group right here right now.
They might have food at their camp, though.
Hang on.
We haven't even talked to these people yet.
Maybe they're not.
they can be helpful yeah yeah these are people people trying to survive just like us we've got to stick together to survive yeah the only reason you're here is because you had food enough okay then go start your own group that food is almost gone we've got maybe a week's worth left and i vote lily and larry out no fine you guys fight it out then welcome to the family kid what what but they I'm over here and see what I drew.
What the?
What?
No, I...
Just come on, okay?
You like to think you're the leader of this little group, but we can make our own goddamn decisions.
This isn't your own personal dictatorship.
Oh, come on.
You're being dramatic.
Everything always turns into a power struggle between you two.
I'm not going to be a part of that.
Hey, I didn't ask to lead this group.
Everyone was happy to have me distributing the food when there was enough to go around.
But now that it's running out, suddenly I'm a goddamn Nazi.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter who's in charge.
Yeah.
Those people are here now.
I guess we just have to decide what happens next.
No, Lee, it does matter.
One person can't be in charge of everything.
You know, it might feel safe for you to sit on the fence.
You tried to stay neutral.
But sooner or later, you're going to have to decide whose side you're on.
Ugh.
Definitely not hers.
I don't see any of you stepping up to make the hard decisions.
My girl's got more balls than all of you combined.
Ew, look at her smiling.
Dad, please.
You go help Mark with the wall.
I'm gonna murder this man.
You think this is easy for me?
Everyone's starting to hate me because I'm the one that rations the food.
But nobody else wants to.
I mean, she's got a point though.
Someone has to do it.
You know what?
I'm not doing it tonight.
You do it.
There's today's food rations, but there's not enough for everyone.
Good luck.
That's it?
Some cheese and crackers?
Yummy.
I hope tomorrow is also cheese and crackers.
You have four items.
Four food items for ten hungry people.
Okay, Larry gets none.
You want me in charge?
Fine.
Be nice to me.
Oh.
Give food to Katya.
Is that how you say her name?
I don't remember.
Let's see how she's doing there.
Is he going to be okay?
I don't know.
Can you give me a hand real quick?
Yeah.
What do you need?
Sure.
Just apply some pressure here while I try to close this up.
You know, I thought I was starting to get used to this.
Sewing up people's injuries.
But I mean, cuts and bruises are one thing.
But wait, this man has no leg.
I did that.
It's what your husband wanted.
Figures.
I love that man to death, but I swear sometimes he's dumber than a bag of hammers.
I mean, well, what else was I supposed to do?
Thanks for the help.
Go ahead and check in on the others.
I need a little space here anyway.
Oh, I didn't do it.
What's this?
Bookcase.
Steady.
Better snack will hold up forever, just like the rest of this place.
Whoa.
His voice was, like, reverberating through my brain.
Dumpsters.
We dug through those for food a long time ago.
Um...
Soup?
We got soup?
Will you hold the damn board steady?
I'm trying.
I didn't realize I was getting this week already.
What do you want?
A handout?
Oh, I got 60 cents in my pocket.
If you'll shut up and quit being such a pansy.
No food for Larry.
This guy is so rude.
It keeps the walkers out.
Carly's been doing the bulk of the lookout duty.
Hello, Mark.
His name is Mark.
You holding up okay, Lee?
That was pretty fucked up back there.
Having to cut that guy's leg off.
It was awesome.
I just hope Kanja can save him.
Oh, hi, Mark.
Oh, want some food?
Gives food.
Ever missed the Air Force Base?
Lily's pretty pissed at us.
Maybe Larry, not Larry, maybe Mark doesn't get food because he missed that bird.
Hmm.
Do you deserve this, Mark?
Do you deserve my cheese and crackers?
we have to be we have to be uh very careful i'll just ask him about the air force base you ever miss the air force base i mean this wall isn't exactly military standard no way i'm going back there you saw what it was like when you guys picked me up completely overrun did you bring food lily's pretty pissed at us pretty pissed at us listen I know her intentions are good,
but...
But nothing!
She's making the smart choice.
Those parasites you guys brought back need to go.
Good Lord!
Could Chat have some cheese and crackers?
Okay, don't tell anybody, but I'm gonna give it all to us instead, okay?
Nobody else is gonna get the cheese and crackers.
It's all us, baby.
I always wonder, though, is it just because it's so difficult to go outside in these types of situations to find food?
I mean, I know a lot of stuff is perishable, but just find a vending machine or something.
I don't know.
It can be.
No power.
Just break it open.
No electricity.
You have a hammer, you know, to crash it, to smash it.
Nobody to fill the vending machine.
What?
No, those fill magically.
Obviously, okay, let's go.
Need any help with the wall?
Nope.
Actually, we could use your axe.
Do you mind if we take it?
Don't give it to Larry.
Yeah, give us that thing for a bit.
Give to Mark.
Oh, wait, I actually get to make the decision.
Do you think we could convince Larry to be our friend?
Or is he a lost cause?
I think he'll kill Mark.
Give to Mark.
Here, Mark, this should help.
Hey, I'm the one doing all the work over here.
You didn't think to give me the axe?
Come on, Larry.
Give it a rest.
I'm sure Lee is getting pretty sick of you thinking he's a danger to the group.
Is that what you told him?
Um, I mean, I did say that.
Yeah, I'll go up to it.
What are you going to do about it?
Look, I don't care what it is, but you two have got to start trying to get along.
The only thing I have to do is protect my daughter.
Get out of here.
Why is now that means getting this damn wall fixed?
So I would appreciate it if you two would shut up and let me get back to work.
Why doesn't he just leave then?
Kiss him.
Oh, his glasses are...
Wait, that's not how you use an axe, Mark.
Mark.
I thought he was gonna, like, chop up more wood to put it on.
I guess if you don't have a hammer, that's so funny.
Let's make Larry even more angry.
I agree.
Lily and Kenny need to get along.
Lily wants to ditch the new people.
He's going to agree with her.
Lily and Kenny need to get along.
You've got to talk to Lily about getting along with Kenny.
Lily can make her own friends.
It's not about making friends.
We're all in this together.
We got to start acting like it.
Yeah.
Stuff all that.
We'd be fine without you.
Okay, never mind.
I don't want to talk to Larry anymore.
Keep up on that fence.
Don't tell me what to do, Lee.
Good Lord.
Let's go give Clementine her food.
At least the kids have something to keep them occupied.
Mark is to axes, but Carly is to batteries.
How you doing, Clementine?
Okay.
Where's your hat?
I don't know.
Can you help me find it?
No, you're hot.
Sure.
Yeah.
Anything.
for you i had it a couple days ago i promise if i find it i'll let you know how thank you what okay you don't leave the place where else could it be some things why don't you go back to playing with duck for a while okay you don't leave this place where could else where could it have gone what's your name oh ben hi ben hey is my friend gonna make it your teacher but kaja will do her best i promise shaggy i can't believe you talk off his leg there was no other way you would have lost two friends so who are you so who are you people our group's gonna want to know I'm Ben Ben Paul man you saved is mr.
Parker the band director at my school we all came down from Stone Mountain for the playoffs when when everything happened how are you holding up how you holding up kid well I I keep wondering if I could have done something to help you know some kind of I don't know something oh I don't know you'll be prepared be prepared next time yeah next time yeah it's gonna happen again relax we'll get your friend back to normal in no time I sure hope so yeah Ben you gotta be you gotta be prepared okay we're gonna give Clementine some food
Oh, you still have that walkie-talkie?
It was the broken one.
That thing doesn't work anymore, does it?
No, not since it broke at the drugstore.
Yeah.
Just gonna hold on to it then?
Yeah, if that's okay, I...
Ben is the worst?
You don't like him?
It's okay, Han.
I won't give him food, then.
I don't know him, so.
I know, I did.
And until then...
Look, Clementine.
I'm not stupidly.
I know it's just pretend.
but it makes me feel better okay you take good care of it then duck is the worst is there anyone good besides clementine how you doing clementine everything all right yeah is that man going to be okay uh i'm not sure i'm not sure i hope you will i'm so hungry lee i hope i get to eat soon is my command my sweet when I stood up just to get back down here Clem you need something to eat yeah give her crackers and cheese okay a Sunday would be better next time you chose to take care of Clementine I'll keep that in mind if you have any more food.
Duck is hungry too.
Oh.
Yeah, why don't we get some food?
Duck is hungry, huh?
Oh.
I mean, I'm gonna save the jerky for, like, someone that needs, like, some good protein, you know?
Someone that goes outside.
Maybe Kenny.
Kenny can have the jerky maybe do it for kenny okay duck can have an apple how are you doing duck i'm okay me and clementine are coloring guess what it is i don't know a dog nope oh i know it's a goat right oh no what i think duck huh
Ben okay I don't know Ben but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna say that Ben sucks yeah you were pretty brave when we brought those people in here that's cuz I know mom can fix him okay I'll give you I'll give you an apple for Kenny I'm out a little food
yeah yeah boy you want some food yeah yeah you want some food yeah yeah here's an apple here oh heck yes is there peanut butter that's a great question oh my gosh what do you think duck no probably not wait i love apple's peanut butter yum yummy
sleeping any better sleeping any better no i know we should be grateful for beds but no duck has taste yeah i love apples and peanut butter yeah vtuber eat peanut butter i might i might i'm giving out food what should i do has me handing out the food that can't be an easy job it's not i won't be able to feed everyone what should i do peanut butter well if you wanted to get in good with lily i'd make sure larry gets some food We used to call it a peanut butter lick.
Dick sometimes.
On the other hand, giving that food to Kenny and his family might make him remember you.
She would be like, Minto, do you want a peanut butter lick?
I'd be like, yes, man.
I want peanut butter lick.
I can't tell you what to do.
But whatever happens, I know you'll be trying to do the right thing.
Thanks, Carly.
Wait, what did you say?
Hi, Minto.
Hi, Reese.
All right.
Never had a squeeze packet.
It's just like jelly.
Squeeze packet.
Of peanut butter?
Did you listen to her?
No.
Back in a bit.
Sorry.
I was too busy thinking about peanut butter.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Canny.
He's mad at me.
want to leave the motor in oh yeah that ain't no secret lee it's probably our best bet look you've been good to me and my family you saved duck from those monsters and you stood up to larry at the drugstore yeah i won't forget that yeah you and clem are welcome to come with we should we should go the coast does sound like a smart idea i agree does sound like a smart idea yeah yeah yeah we should go we should go i know there it is i'm taking my family you told kenny leaving for the coast was a good idea kenny there's some food want something to eat jorky give a piece of jerky here kenny take this how about my boy he eat yet he did yeah i gave him something sure then hand it over i'm starved thanks the others noticed you fed kenny kenny is my bud I don't care if they notice the last piece for your oh
I was gonna give it to to our lady friend maybe we only maybe the only people that eat are the ones that are leaving some
of these people have gone longer than me without food They're the ones that need it.
Is the last piece peanut butter flavored?
No, it's cheese crackers.
Which also sounds great, but...
I gotta talk to Lily, too.
How's it going, Lee?
From up here, it looks like you're playing favorites.
Um, ma'am?
I was about to eat...
I should have eaten those damn crackers.
Screw you!
We should think about leaving here.
Let's talk about you and Kenny.
We should talk about you and Kenny.
What about us?
Rude!
It's getting pretty out of hand.
You know people notice that.
You're rude.
Look, I'm working my ass off to make sure we have a good setup here, and Kenny just doesn't appreciate that.
All we need is food.
That's true.
But there is no food.
Start a garden!
You know that better than anyone.
Well, we'll just have to find some.
Start foraging.
Make sure Mark doesn't miss the shot.
Oh, we should think about leaving here.
I wonder if she will.
Maybe we should think about leaving the motel.
God, not you too.
I know Kenny wants to leave.
I think that's why he's so eager to get the RV working.
But this is a good spot.
We're protected.
We're close to the drugstore.
We have a routine now and it's working.
For now.
I trust in Kenny.
Me too.
Yeah, you can't really grow a garden in the parking lot.
That's why you need to leave.
Keep an eye out.
Fine.
Who should I give the last...
We should have, like, a...
A talent show.
Winner gets crackers.
He looks so suspicious.
When he's, like, he's, like, side-eyeing.
Um...
Yeah, we'll give it to our lady friend.
Carly can't shoot.
That's so true.
Carly, I give the food to you.
Want something to eat?
Give crackers and cheese.
Here.
Me?
How about you?
You look like crap, Lee.
When was the last time you ate?
I'm okay.
I want you to have this, okay?
In case you or Clementine starts feeling weak.
Oh!
I know I said it didn't matter why you saved me instead of Doug, but...
You don't know me.
anything carly dog i should have i should have i should have saved dog carly's so nice though she's so good maybe we give it to katya we feed kenny's whole family part of me almost wants to feed lily just so she shuts up for a bit trying to think i wish it had said like who hasn't eaten last you know
but she is the nurse yeah she's fixing up a guy's leg right now which is pretty spooky I'll give the food to her why don't you give it to Doc I'm a little busy with your mess right now I need space Lee I tried okay I'll give it to Lily I feel like someone made a good point maybe Lily isn't a bad idea because it'll turn her against her dad yeah but her dad will probably be really mad too that i'm talking to his daughter
i'm not gonna give anything to mark i don't know that guy and also he he was overly confident and he swung and missed and he needs to be punished okay
i'll give it to her honestly everybody else is rejecting it so okay give food to lily here i don't want anything from you.
Fine!
Don't eat!
That's that scene in Beauty and the Beast.
Then go ahead and starve!
Bitch!
Fuck off!
I'm eating this for myself!
Can I eat the crackers now?
What about Ben?
I don't know that guy either.
Okay, Mark.
It's your lucky day.
Give it to Clem.
We already gave her some.
I don't think it'll let us give a second one.
Here, eat something.
Yeah, there's crackers and cheese.
Thanks, Lee.
There we go.
All gone!
Right in front of Larry.
Yeah, you should...
Yeah, yeah, you should feel bad.
Not such an easy job, is it?
Never said it was.
What?
I don't envy you.
I don't know how you have the strength to do this every day.
I don't have a choice.
Larry must...
buffer.
Hey, thanks for looking out for me and my family.
I'm serious about that offer to come with us.
You've more than earned a ride on the RV with me.
Still, I guess some people aren't going to be happy with your choices.
You're out!
What happened to my food?
There's none left.
You keep treating people like this, and your days in this group are numbered.
You're one to talk, old man.
Yeah, well, I don't see you working on that wall.
He was out.
side-working That's why he gets to take a rest Ken Lee come here, please.
Oh my god.
He didn't make it did he?
Oh He lost too much blood.
Oh god.
God damn it.
I'm getting sick of this shit Ken come back.
There's nothing.
Uh, I'm sick of this shit, too.
I'm sick of this shit, too You don't think I am?
Maybe it's for the best.
Yeah, we're already struggling to feed our own kids That man you brought, I tried, but he was never going to survive.
It's okay, it's not your fault.
I'm not a problem anymore.
Damn.
What about the other kid?
Eww.
What the?
Uh, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Uh, what am I supposed to do?
Ow!
Hello?
Oh, that's what I'm supposed to do.
Oh my god, Mark!
Mark!
Use the S key.
Mark, please.
I fed you, Mark, and it was a mistake!
you do mark
is never get that strike too buddy why'd you bring him here in the first place how did he how did he change you're gonna get us all killed you said he wasn't bitten what we asked you point-blank was he bitten yeah said no he wasn't well you're not bitten friend here came back to life and tried to kill my wife what wait you all don't know what the hell are you talking about huh Actually,
I don't know.
It's not the bite that does it.
You come back no matter how you die.
If you don't destroy the brain, that's just what happens.
Whoa.
It's going to happen to all of us.
What?
We're all infected?
We're all infected.
Everyone?
I guess so.
Is this actually real?
I, all I know is that I've seen people turn who I know were never bitten.
When I first saw it happen.
We were all hiding out in a gym and everybody thought we were finally safe.
Oh my god.
One of the girls Jenny pitcher, I think Jenny pitcher.
She took some pills.
A lot of them.
Oh Someone went in the girls's room the next morning.
I definitely missed us in the TV show Back off Whoa lady relax me and my brother.
We we just want to know if y'all can help us out.
I said back off Carly uh are you are you armed are you armed yeah for protection that was a dumb question that could be anywhere but uh i think you got the upper hand here why do you need gas our place is protected by an electric fence generators provide the electricity our generators run on gas we own a dairy farm a few miles up the road y'all be willing to lower your guns we can talk about How y'all doing on food?
We got plenty at the dairy.
I don't trust him.
Lee, why don't you and Mark check the place out?
See if it's legit.
I'm going with you.
Yeah, please.
Don't leave me alone with Mark.
Wait.
What do y'all think?
Don't leave me alone with Mark.
Is this a trap?
We'll go for the content.
You've got a deal.
We'll bring some gas to you.
everyone should go wait what do you mean some food to bring back see how it goes from there decided everyone should go i didn't decide a couple gallons should power one of our generator i didn't decide this so this dairy you guys really have food sure do we lost most of the cattle but we still have lots of milk butter and cheese stock oh my god there's ben and with the vegetables we grow we got plenty of food it's nice to get away from that motel for a while this lily can Anything is starting to get ridiculous.
I agree.
Personally, I'd be happier if you started to take charge more.
Me as a leader?
You think they'd want me for a leader?
Sure.
Everybody looks up to you.
Really?
Not everyone thinks I'm so trustworthy.
Because of your past.
Does anyone else know?
Larry knows.
Great.
That can't be easy.
Clementine might know.
Oh yeah, she does know.
does know talking in the drugstore and ask me about his marksmanship sucks yeah what exactly did happen with the senator uh now is not the time now it's not the time well i'm here whenever you want to talk sometimes i wonder if i should talk to the group about it you don't have to whatever happened before things went to hell doesn't matter anymore i mean not sure everyone would see it that way maybe you're right but like it's also a judge of his character i've reported on some pretty messed up shit.
I've seen situations like yours a hundred times.
It doesn't have to make you a bad man.
I, uh, really appreciate that.
Like, I get it.
I get your viewpoint, but at the same time, it's just like, oh, just because someone was a serial killer.
Before things... Before things happen, doesn't mean that they're not going to be a serial killer now.
Uh, I grew up in...
I grew up in Macon.
Right here in the heart of Georgia.
That's what I like to hear.
Y'all seem that motor in who's running things over there it's a democracy oh me I am you guys have any questions you come to me how many people you got over there anyway change the subject well the kid here's our newest arrival but we're all looking forward to some food we really need it well here's to helping each other I'm not gonna tell you how many people we have get you all out to the Like I said,
we got plenty of food.
Quite frankly, we could always use an extra help in hand.
In the summers, I used to help out on a goat farm.
Yeah, that's great.
Everything helps.
Mama's been running the dairy for as long as I can remember, but now it's...
You think you're going to cut me out of this?
Shit, get down.
No one's trying to cut you out of anything.
You and Carrie are always pulling this shit.
Who?
Those look like the people who raided my camp.
Who are they?
Fuck you!
You knew we were hungry, and you guys were keeping it off of yourselves.
Oh, no.
There's a lot more.
We ate it all.
What are you gonna fucking do about it?
Don't worry.
Danny and I got you covered if something happens.
Oh, yeah?
Let's just wait this out.
I don't think you do.
Fuck you!
Oh!
Jesus!
Asshole!
Oh!
Me to Larry.
Come on.
Holy hell.
Let's get to the dairy where it's safe.
He shot him in the brain, right?
He's not going to turn.
Waste of ammo.
Yeah, and it also sound like you're going to attract them.
Here it is.
Wait, they do have a farm.
St. John's Family Dairy.
Five, five, five.
And y'all can see how he kept this place so safe.
For all yours.
keeps them out they are you betcha they fry like bugs and a zapper we're pushing 4,000 boats through that thing with generators and amps I'm going to assume that's a lot
we can't have the kids around the fence oh I like it this is a really brilliant setup suits us just fine this place looks untouched you never know the rest of the world is in ruins it's worth protecting hence all the I thought I saw y'all with company coming down the drive.
Are they cannibals?
This is our mama.
I'm Brenda St. John and welcome to the St. John Dairy.
This here's Lee.
He's from Macon.
A couple of our old farm hands were from Macon.
They grow them good there.
They got a few more friends staying at the old motel.
Are they cannibals?
Oh my goodness, that place is pretty vulnerable.
Have you got someone with survival experience to lead your group?
We work together.
We all work together.
Plus, we've got plenty of people with military experience.
Well, that's good to hear.
That motel ain't the safest place.
Hold on, I thought you said someone else was running things.
Oh yeah, I thought she was asking about survival tactics.
Oh yeah.
Well, it don't matter.
You're here now.
We'll make sure you're safe and comfortable.
Are you cannibals?
Does that offer?
Does that offer apply to the rest of us?
we're all incredibly hungry these are far y'all bake fresh this morning amazing can't get stuff like that anymore not without a cow for milk and butter that's for sure that's right hopefully maybell will make it through this bout of whatever she's got and be with us for a good long while you guys we have a vet we could bring her here we can help you folks out oh a vet oh my our prayers group could come for the day well how about this y'all go get your veterinary friend and I'll prepare some dinner a big feast for all you hungry souls it'll be nice to have some folks to help out around here again Danny why don't you come help me out in the kitchen why don't I head back with the food and round up everyone for the trip over here I'd want to take someone with you remember those roads can be dangerous I can handle myself take this Why don't you go ahead and take Ben along anyway?
Take care of yourself, Lee.
See you in a while.
We don't know Ben.
Oh, the foreshadowing is...
That little linger on the fence?
I could use some help securing the perimeter.
I don't know if I like that.
Sometimes the dead get tangled up in the fence before they fry and end up knocking over a post.
It'd be a big help if you could walk the perimeter.
You can learn a little something about our fence.
I'm going to go top off the generators before they run dry.
give me when you're ready you betcha this place is incredible it's got food and that fence oh man stop talking about the fence you're scared our cards right this might turn out to be a place we can stay so how do you want to play this I think they're pushing people onto the fence and then once they get nice and crispy they're let's make sure the place is safe before we can think about bringing our whole group here to stay we need to figure out if this place is as safe as they're telling us yeah right obviously they think it's safe but is it safe enough for the kids I noticed a broken swing over there not a big deal but maybe there's other things not working that we just can't see and checking the fence perimeter sounds like a decent way to get a good look at the fences all right I'll keep my eyes open and you find out what you can from Andy well you can't see it but it actually says st.
John Donner party I don't trust these people at all I don't trust them one bit what's that pointy why don't you say that look at the boy but they go through a lot of wood keeping those fences repaired saw if a couple of tools out in the open is as unsafe as it gets we'll be fine here would have been nice to have one of these back at the motor in.
You had an axe.
And some people, some people don't know how to use it.
Looks like the fence runs around the entire property, not just the house.
Don't even think about licking it.
Can't take any chances when it comes to safety.
Why are you so focused on cannibalism?
Is that what happened to your body?
Well, they're just, they're just so confident.
Wait, if I get close to it, can I die?
They're just so confident about not being hungry.
Where's the cow?
Okay, so they definitely...
They do have corn, it looks like, over there.
And what's up with this broken swing, huh?
They had a kid that they ate?
Too bad it's broken.
I'll bet Clementine and Duck would have loved something like this to play.
I don't think we should...
Kids used to like that old swing even more than the tour sometimes.
I don't think we should have them swinging by a...
4,000-volt fence.
How did it break?
Got busted the first day those things showed up.
Thank God no one was on it at the time.
Looks like it just needs a new board for the sea.
Some rope.
Make it safe for Clem and Duck.
And let the St. John's know we can pull our weight around.
Cannibalism core family.
It's true, it's true, it's true.
I think they're cannibals.
Well, you know...
I'm fine with being a cannibal.
Give me that sweet, sweet brain amoeba.
You know, what's it called when you eat people and you get that thing in your brain that's basically equivalent to mad cow disease?
Pryons.
Yeah, give me the prions.
Oh, we're just going inside.
Oh, they have awards now.
This dairy won a lot of ribbons in its day, huh?
Where's the cow?
This place was my daddy's life.
It meant everything to him.
Where's the cow?
You know, when he first bought this place, it was a single-story house.
Is that right?
After us kids was born, he insisted on adding a second floor.
He said they had to have room for as many babies as they could have.
Mama, she was done after Dan.
My folks stopped after two as well.
Then one day, the world changed.
Now this place is all we have left of daddy.
That's why we take such good care of it, and why we want to share it with good folks like yourselves.
St. John's, Johnner Party.
Ooh, fresh herbs.
I can hardly wait for dinner.
So relaxing.
Used to have these on the front porch of my house growing up.
The noise doesn't attract any unwanted guests.
That's what I'm saying.
Can I just go inside?
Hello?
She says, oh, hi there, Lee.
Dinner.
What can I do for you?
Dinner's here.
I mean, dinner's ready.
I think with Danny's help, I've got things pretty well squared away in the kitchen.
But feel free to check with Andy.
He's got a lot of weight on his shoulders these days, so I'm sure he'd love any help he can do.
How many rooms in this house?
When will dinner be ready?
Dinner will be ready as soon as everybody's here.
It'll be a while still, but it'd be worth it.
Trust me.
A while?
About the length that it takes to get to the motel and back?
your family's done an amazing job of keeping this place up well now aren't you sweet thank you lou the boys and i have tried to adapt as best we can but we still keep some of our old routines to help remind us of better times like eating did you always eat people what happened to your staff oh they ate dinner what happened to the rest of your staff oh we've had our share of tragedy here just like everyone else i'm sure some of our staff took off to find their family as soon as they heard the news the few that stuck around well we lost show me your beds yeah things showed up here it was a tough night i like how she's it cut from her being all sad to to smiling smiling also dairy of the year 1993 when does this take place when does the what is the timeline here How many rooms does this house have?
Rooms?
Why do you add?
1991.
Uh, just curious?
Oh, uh, just curious, I guess.
Phil, welcome back to theCUBE.
Let's not start thinking too far ahead.
Welcome to membership, thank you.
Let's just focus on getting y'all a good home-cooked meal tonight.
Well, if anything comes up that I can help with, feel free to let me know.
Well, Lee, I sure appreciate it.
No problem.
She will remember that.
Oh, okay.
Let's go talk to Mark here.
Okay, I don't really like Mark.
I miss Doug.
So what have you found out?
Is this looking like a good place to stay?
That fence is no joke.
The fence is no joke.
At least around the house.
I'm looking forward to seeing the rest of you.
I'll keep looking around.
All right, keep me posted.
I wouldn't be having my hand on the post even like it's I think I would stay far far away.
Oh, what's this?
Outlet you can definitely tell they built this thing themselves
I can use the gate hey, what are you fixing to do around the barn?
Just trying to help out just trying to find more ways to help out.
Yeah, well, I I appreciate that.
Tell you what, we'll find you something to do over there after we get back from securing the perimeter.
Sounds good.
Where's your cow?
I haven't heard a single moo.
What's that?
Generator.
You guys come along with gas just in time.
Hey, uh, don't mess with that, okay?
The thing's a little tricky and I don't want to spend half a day trying to fix it again.
this is like a lot of maintenance you know like you would have to always be getting gas sus so sus very sus hi hi I'm glad you guys decided to help us out I noticed back in the motel that you folks are pretty well armed been stockpiling huh how many weapons do you have no one fuck yeah anyone tries to fuck with us they'll regret it well protecting your people is important but my experience having that many guns around is when people get dangerous are we your first guests we can't be the first people you've invited up to the dairy well no we've made similar deals with other folks trading for gas and food but ultimately they moved on looking for the people they lost contact with You found out the other survivors.
The other survivors have stayed at the farm.
Yeah, they were delicious.
Yeah, we traded their bodies for food.
The fence stops the walkers?
An electric fence is enough to keep out walkers?
Walkers?
Is that what you call them?
That's good.
The old one wouldn't have, but Mac, he was our foreman, he figured out how to amp it up with the generators.
We used to sit out here some nights and watch the sons of bitches sizzling pop when they got too close.
closest thing to entertainment these days i guess these generators are enough to power the whole dairy we got lots and gotta keep trading for fuel as much as we can but they all work together to do the trick you know like us mark and i can help you with that perimeter now oh good here we go fence will stop a walker in about three or four seconds but gets overloaded if we leave the husks out there you know mark and i can clear the fence ourselves if you want to stay here and finish up with the generators.
Well, that'd be great.
I'm scared.
I'll turn off the northwest section, and if you guys could strip them off and look for any weak points, well, that'd be a big help.
Stay attentive.
We never know.
Oh, wow.
Wow, that's a huge perimeter.
Holy moly.
Is it safe enough for us to stay?
If we can?
It's pretty amazing what they've done with this dairy, but...
Let's see what it takes to secure this fence before drawing any conclusions.
I can't wait until everyone's out here.
Everyone besides Larry.
What's up with you telling him what I said about him thinking I'm dangerous?
Look, you said it.
You even admitted it right to him.
Well, I try to be civil.
I try to be civil at least.
He's too busy being cranky to notice.
Ew!
There's one.
Is that thing dead?
Are we sure?
Ugh.
Are we 100% sure that thing's dead?
Lee, it's dead.
I'm trying to be careful.
Andy said, when this fence is working, the walkers go up like a tree branch on a power line.
If those lights are out, that means the fence is off, right?
It better be.
Who do you think he was?
I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
Maybe the St. John boys are using this guy for target practice?
Ah, poor guy.
I don't know what got him first, the arrow or the fence.
Either way, hope he was already dead.
Push the zombie.
Looks like he's stuck.
Oh, no!
Push the zombie.
Push him again.
Looks like he's stuck.
Uh...
I have two prompts.
Pull the arrow out.
Oh, yeah, oh, because he's stuck from the arrow.
I think.
Disgusting.
Push the zombie.
Ooh, it's hot.
I'm sure there's still a few more.
I don't know if I was walking that or not.
Once this fence is patched up, this place will be a fortress.
God, can you imagine not having to worry about the walkers anymore?
A fortress needs people to...
Yeah, it's useless without gas.
Well, it's useless without gas.
We might need food, but the St. John's need gas, too.
Not many drivers these days, Lee.
We could scrounge up a year's worth of gas.
Easy.
So what's your take on the brothers?
They seem to have this place tied down pretty well.
What do you...
They're delaying the inevitable.
What do you mean by that?
I don't know.
They seem decent enough.
We don't know.
I just want you to know that I've got your back if anything goes down.
Well, where's the cow?
There's another one.
I see it.
Oh, my gosh.
This one dead.
Is this one dead?
Uh...
Let go!
Man, the fence burned right into its hands.
Think they fused together?
Dead, dead.
Oh, okay.
Think they fused together.
Eww.
Chop.
Chop, chop!
Chop, chop, chop.
You never get used to the smell, do you?
Nope.
Oh, we're just gonna leave the hands?
Christ.
I can't stop thinking about dinner.
It's you, buddy.
Thanks for the rations earlier.
It's not easy eating in front of the kids, but it's all that's keeping me on my feet right now.
I can't have them food, too.
Uh, we'll go ask for more to eat after.
Focus on the task.
Just try to focus on the task.
They knew what they were doing, teasing us food and then giving us chores having a good meal will be worth it oh my gosh this guy really took out I think I see where they're getting in this one must have knocked it over trying to get through he's tangled up in there pretty good come on help me get this thing back in place so we can get mr.
crispy off of here think we get better leverage from the other side good idea okay oh I have a little help here Lee hold on I'm looking at this guy if you're waiting for that guy to help it ain't gonna happen come on oh okay gosh
holy fuck what just happened the fences are on why the hell would he turn the fence on he knows we're out here what the hell get to Okay
Who the fuck is that no idea fuck now now On that gate it's our only way out Uh Uh, oh gosh, uh What is that?
Oh my gosh
Uh, if I look up...
Oh wait, oh...
Oh, I didn't get to the sea!
Oh no!
I push it?
What about all the arrangements?
Push it?
No?
Doesn't work?
Wait, what was that?
Hey, let's talk this out!
Oh no, they know!
They knew we're here!
Oh, wait!
Pull that.
Maybe.
Ow!
You didn't deliver the goods!
The goods?
Okay, it should move now, no?
Okay, I thought it was like stuck in the ground.
I already got one of you!
You fuck with us!
Can I do anything on the tractor?
Oh, here we go.
Of course.
Uh...
It doesn't have a gear though.
Oh, oh, go do it.
Oh, that was close.
Is there anything else over here?
Ah, fuck you, asshole.
I already got one of you.
I already got one.
Oh, this thing.
I just saw it.
There we go.
Come on.
If we can reach the gate, we can get through this fence and back to the house.
Shit.
Oh,
no, it's gonna run over the zombie.
What happened?
It's one of the dead we pushed down earlier.
I'm gonna have to move it.
What about our arrangement?
Don't think I can't see you.
Oh, baby, I can't see you.
Okay, keep going.
Easy peasy.
Oh my gosh, another body.
Another one?
How many of those things did we push down?
Not that many.
No, you don't.
You don't see me.
Oh my gosh, why is he still alive?
Why is he still alive?
Hey, chill out.
Oh my gosh.
Holy hell.
You okay?
Yeah.
Barely.
Come on.
Oh my god, he's coming after us!
That's crazy.
Oh my god!
That's so cool.
Let's get out of here.
Wait, I think you should close that.
I think you should have closed that.
No?
Okay.
Lee, what's wrong?
It was an ambush.
There was a goddamn ambush out there.
Holy shit, are you okay?
Bandits here?
On our property.
They could just follow me.
Oh my lord, what happened to you, sweetheart?
What's those bastards in the woods, Mama?
Yeah, I'll be alright once it's out.
God damn, it hurts.
Hey, y'all.
Uh-huh.
Oh my god.
What happened?
He got trapped with an arrow.
Christ!
Are you gonna be okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
I should just pull it out.
Oh no, honey.
Come on.
Brenda's got you.
Oh no, no, Brenda.
We'll have you all sorted out.
Brenda's like, oh yeah, he's already skewered.
What kind of shit is this?
We ran into some people on the way up here.
Bandits, I guess.
I think it was them that attacked us.
They gave us a lot of problems in the beginning.
He's already on them.
We were able to get them to stop by making a deal.
these people he's already a little protection not like we had much of a choice but they did stop hassling us god damn it Carly said this place was locked down tight so much for your understanding for your deal those shitheads broke the agreement look I'm sorry Lee if I had any inkling they were gonna give you guys trouble well we would have gone out there with you listen we may have had an agreement with those people but we will not stand for this shit ain't no we're gonna let those sons of bitches get away with this you know where these assholes are they're hard to pin down but I think I know where at least one of their camps are when you're ready to go scope out yeah but the power right pandits are you serious this place isn't safe we can't stay here not safe this place is a hell of a lot safer than that motor in I think all of us in our guns can handle a couple of punks with bows and arrows what we need to do is here to stay take this place over if we have to oh cool your jets there
Rambo these are nice people let's not do anything to get us thrown out before we you don't know them now you think they're nice people you guys should try to make friends with Andy and Brenda while I'm gone well that's easy I got charm coming out of my ass yeah that's real charming dad where's Ben and Carly since Carly and Ben ate some of the food on the way to get us she volunteered to stay behind until we get back oh hey I remember seeing kids in your group so I went ahead and fixed that swing while you were out hope your kids like swings a swing I love swings just like at my tree house come on doc why don't you kids go and play on the swing huh please yeah but the fence anytime we're looking out for you oh God but
the fence is like right there It's like, oh my god, oh, oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, no, no.
Oh, no, I'm trying to watch them.
They look happy.
His expression.
Hey, Clam, do you like the swing?
Yeah, it's fun.
Be sure to tell Andy, thank you, okay?
I will.
Will you push me on it?
Maybe later.
Maybe later, okay?
Oh, okay.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, Clem.
What do you think of the dairy?
It's pretty.
It reminds me of how things used to look before.
Yeah, it does.
Do you think things will ever get back to how they were?
I made her sad.
I'm sorry.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure, Clem.
We'll be honest with her.
She's...
I hope so too.
She's a big girl.
How are you doing?
How you holding up, Clementine?
I'm okay, I guess.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
I'm just a little worried about Mark.
Are we?
going to be okay get lucky out there it'll be a lot worse are you going to find the people who hurt mark yeah we have to make sure they don't hurt anyone else yeah be careful i want you to remember that ever since i met you i've had good luck so don't worry okay lucky guy don't worry we're safe here now as long as the bad people don't feel like i should right i won't let what happened to mark happen to you the word totally safe like you know i promise i've got some things to take be back in a bit okay yeah I'm new to parenting please trying to talk to Keen oh my god why are we going closer to the fence hey hey Lee found anything interesting I'm just trying to make sure this place is secure in case we decide to make this a more long-term solution let Clementine have a chance seems pretty safe good to know keep your ears open for anything else might help us how are you holding up how you holding up I hope they feed us Lee soon on the way over here I was getting dizzy hands shaking cold
sweats I thought I was gonna pass out they've got food here yeah but I'm not just talking about one meal you know I guess Lily isn't too thrilled about being here I could give two shits about what Lily wants duck and Kacha need food I'm not about to sit around that motor in and watch him go hungry mom's you're with me on this right
uh yeah of course yeah of course Lily's judgment is clouded but you got a pretty clear head about this we're on Kenny's side did duck and Kacha get here okay now it wasn't easy duck didn't look so good on the walk over to this I gave duck half an apple everything works out maybe he and Kacha can have an easier life here.
I hope you're right.
Duck and Clementine deserve a better life than starving to death at some crappy motel.
So true.
Don't wait too long to help scope out that bandit camp.
It'd be a good opportunity to find out a bit more about the St. John's and their relationship with those bandits or whatever.
I agree.
Right.
I'll see what I can find out.
Are these all the same as before?
I wonder.
Dang it, Doug.
Let Clementine have a turn on the electric fence.
Yeah!
They're storing gasoline all over the property.
Can I go here yet?
Oh, who that, Larry?
We're going into the barn.
If there's not enough room in the house for all of us, I guess a few of us could camp out here in ships.
Go in.
Go inside.
If there's not enough room in the house for all of us.
I guess a few of us could camp out here in shifts.
Where is the cow?
Hey, pile for cow.
Looks like a feeding station for the cow.
Where is he?
Hello, Larry.
Oh, he doesn't...
We don't even have a prompt for him.
He doesn't want to talk to us at all.
Lee, oh my god.
I'm so glad you two didn't get killed out there.
Do you think Mark will be okay?
Eh, probably.
I think he's...
in good hands now yeah it's not too bad they'll be fine i've seen guys go through worse how could you all bring us to this place what are you talking about about your dad who's sitting right with his eyes rolling okay mister you're gonna eyes just rolled completely into the back of his head oh larry you're gonna give yourself I can't.
Why does he look like that?
Oh my god.
It's like this is his party trick or something.
It's horrible.
What the hell?
He's turning.
I like your dad got bit on the way here.
Oh my gosh.
It's horrifying.
Are you possessed?
We have to worry about zombies.
Zombies and demons About your dad I think we should yeah, is he okay?
Hey, uh, can I talk to you in private before?
Oh, he's fine now.
It's been three months Your dad still treats me like I'm some kind of asshole.
Yeah, well, don't expect that to change.
That's just how he is.
So he's a- wait.
does he treat you like no so he's the asshole look yeah my dad can be an ass sometimes i know that but he's not a bad guy he just he's got a lot of pain that's not an excuse to treat others poorly and lost pretty much everything we all have we all have yeah he's bitter and hateful but that's all just to protect himself and me all he's got left in the world is me that goes both ways you like crap but that's just because he still has one thing left to care about so don't judge him and don't judge me for sticking by him he's my dad and i love him literally everyone has lost something he's not special that's so messed up i guess what's wrong with him what's wrong
don't judge him bit I just trying to do it he's just having a bit of a moment truly I think if you and Kenny didn't exactly make up on the way here I tried seeing things from his point of view having a wife and kid and everything but gambling with your family's life is pretty stupid if you ask me fighting demons he is hey thanks for backing me up this morning at the motel I know I came you guys pretty hard but you do agree with the way i'm running things right uh i don't know kenny i'm kenny believes there's still hope maybe that's what we need right now yeah well hope doesn't do any good if we're all dead i'm focused on getting elderly and not giving my dad food that was cold i don't care okay i don't care hey uh do you think this is a
This is what happens when you don't give him food.
You're not you when you're hungry.
Think our little arrangement with them was a good idea?
A little late to be asking that now, don't you think?
Dad's right.
Let's just wait for dinner.
And then if Mark is feeling up to it, we leave.
I don't want to push our luck here.
Now, let's not be hasty.
How do you feel about it?
about leaving the motor yeah it's a welcome change of scenery she doesn't want to leave though if we just stayed where we were then mark wouldn't have ended up with an arrow in his shoulder yeah but you wouldn't have food either just don't get too nosy these kinds of people are usually pretty protective of their privacy yeah and we don't need you poking your nose where it don't belong and getting us thrown out in our asses okay are you normal now it is normal Oh,
okay, we gotta go this way.
Alrighty, wait, there was nothing over there, so we go through here.
That thing keeps a fence electrified.
Okay, yes, astute observation.
I guess Mark and I were lucky we weren't touching this thing when it came on.
Yeah.
Very, yeah, why did they turn it on?
why did they turn it on we still don't have an answer oh my gosh duck it's get off the swing here I'm gonna ask her if she wants I've got some things to take care of I'll be back in a bit no no okay let's push her please he's been on it the whole time hey Larry meet me over by the fence exactly okay
What is he?
What?
Why didn't he pop out of nowhere like that?
No shit.
You saw what they did to your buddy.
Nobody's safe here until we start to fight back.
But how?
The two of us should go out and do some recon.
Then we'll all mount up for some revenge.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, we can eat all these people in the woods.
We can eat all them instead.
We don't know.
I think some of them used to work in the big box up the way.
The big box?
Yeah, save lots.
Anyway, they're nutty as all hell and get mad when they're hungry.
So, are you ready to head out there and find their camp?
Uh, yeah, we can go.
Yeah, it'll be a good opportunity to find out a bit more about what we're up against.
The guy was like standing there yapping.
I'll stay here and hold down the fort.
Remember, we're just doing the commissons for now.
No use getting ourselves killed.
Oh.
Where are you going now?
Yeah.
I'll be back soon for the time.
Please be lucky.
I will.
Lucky guy.
Aw, Clem.
Wait, it's just the two of us?
That's what we're doing?
See anything?
Not yet.
I'm scared.
I know it's around here.
It's gotta be close.
Soup.
Here.
Oh?
Oh!
Shit, you found it?
Wow, they have a whole really big setup.
Thank you, villain!
Save lots.
Are we going in?
Sneak up to the camp.
I'm sneaking, sneaking mission.
Infiltration.
You see anybody?
Stay on your guard.
Watch my back, Lee.
I'm gonna check out the tent.
Do I see anybody?
Yeah, I do need a crocodile outfit.
OSB.
This camp's too small.
It can't be their main base.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
Take a look around anyway.
There's probably some shit around here they stole from us.
Uh, what was that newspaper?
What was that big old newspaper?
Yuck.
I don't need that.
There was, like, a newspaper that said I'll...
It was...
Bottles?
Kettle?
Oh, no, no, bottle.
Empty.
But it looks like someone's been eating out of these.
Recently.
Gas cam?
Nothing but fuse.
Shit.
The box?
just a box they got what's in the boxes they're all from save lots the first few days they told folks to gather to the save lots by the interstate anything worth taking this is not unless yeah unless you need a bunch of empty cans yeah they're all empty I'll pass
John Terry.
Wait, we'll get that in a second.
Looks like they were moving a lot of stuff.
Hold on.
Was there anything else over here?
Let's check.
The crate?
Nothing.
Nothing here.
The box?
Just a box?
Okay.
Wait.
What is it?
What?
What was... What?
Looks like they expected to be here a while.
Tent looks pretty new.
Anybody inside?
Two sleeping bags.
One of them's kid-sized.
That doesn't seem like a bandit.
That doesn't...
from the dairy here oh probably a food we've been giving them fuckers cross the line what
do you find a video camera let me see that uh-oh why are you stuttering for sorry i didn't mean to actually stutter too good good what else they got over here let's see if we can find anything useful and then get a move on i see you handle that gun i lent you pretty well You a hunter?
No, but Lily keeps us all on a regular training schedule Lily I thought you were running things back there.
Yeah, but she's got the combat training.
Why is that so suspicious?
Yeah, someone else can teach how to use things Why are you acting so weird?
Huh?
Get Carly to put batteries in I Thought I looked at everything around here No?
Is there anything else I'm missing?
Let me go look at the tent again.
Oh, okay, now that he's not in there, we can look.
Bloody bunny!
Wait!
Are these the real people of the dairy farm, you think?
You think...
You think the brothers there don't actually own the dairy farm?
Jesus.
There's a kid mixed up in this?
was more like more like what's that
the hell don't you fucking move shit put your guns down I ain't going back you tell him Jolene ain't going back oh look hey we had a deal no shooting as long as we gave you food what the fuck happened you had a deal with them I ain't them I know you I know what you are,
and I know what you do.
A cannibal!
You don't know me.
Steal my shit.
Steal everything from me.
We had a deal.
You people broke it first.
What happened?
Why are you alone up here?
What happened to you?
Yeah, what happened?
Well, that's a hell of a question, mister.
They told me I'd be safe with them.
Men who lived here, but it weren't safe.
Not for me.
Not for my girl.
They didn't treat her nice.
Not at all.
They took her away into the woods.
wouldn't tell me where and I baked them every way I could think they just laughed so I killed them and I'm staying here till she comes back to me one way or another she'll come back now maybe you didn't hear me last time when I asked you sweet put your damn guns down you think I won't kill you I'm gonna take this here crossbow and put a nice sharp arrow right through your eyeball into your goddamn brain you're not men you're monsters all men are monsters take what they want them and destroy it all take a can of where did you get Clementine's hat it's all the fucking thing you where did you get this hat the little girl you stole it from her so what if I did you stole her from me wait what huh what the hell are you talking about you know what I changed my mind I'm putting this arrow right through your balls yeah right through string him up on that tree then I'm gonna head down to that arm and shoot every goddamn person I see put down the crossbow no sir I need it I need it to kill you
fuckers oh wait go on tell him boy tell him what you got in mind how
Damn.
God damn it!
Uh...
Thanks, I guess.
I guess.
Well, you're welcome, I guess.
Notice my suspicion.
It's a clean shot, though.
Right through the forehead.
That's good shooting right there.
Still, what a waste.
so that's it going back if they ain't here I don't know where they are and it ain't a good idea to go tromping through the woods looking for them so yeah we head back once they see this they'll get the message well she said she wasn't with them take the crossbow at least oh the brain matter
come on
how did she have Clementine's hide
Huh?
Waste of what?
I write?
Your balls will remember that.
They spared our balls.
Man, that was a hell of a ride, huh?
Jesus, Denny.
What?
You ain't getting soft on, Maria.
Not after what they did to your friend.
You're back!
What happened?
Handled it, Mama.
That was it.
waste I guess they like them fresh this isn't what Terry would have wanted my husband miss him every day then screw it up for everybody then why don't you oh calm down princess I'll do it myself how did she steal Clementine's high like where did she get it what's going on with them don't know squabbling looks like a lot of tension with y'all huh yeah you're telling me you could say that Yeah,
you could say that.
They don't exactly see eye to eye on how we should be doing things.
Well, it's probably just the hunger talking.
And Lee, don't worry your head about them bandits.
I'm sorry you've seen more violence than I've thought in your short time, but you are safe here.
Don't worry.
Think I'll go have a look around.
Is dinner ready?
Oh, okay.
Dinner will be ready before you know it.
I thank your friend.
Sometimes her face looks like that one guy that everybody says dream looks like.
A little like leprechaun guy.
I don't know what he's from.
Glim!
Wait.
Are you playing with a cow?
Grumple stiltskin?
Yeah!
That guy.
Let's talk to Danny.
Hello.
Glad I got to use her today My girl here You run this place with just one cow?
How do you run this place with just one cow?
Used to have more They get hungry too Or sick Got your doctor friend What are you gonna do when you run out of one cow You guys must trade for a lot of fuel to keep the generators running, right?
People get hungry And a few loaves of bread fetch a high price Y'all are luckier on this side of the deal now You really like that gun.
Like your girlfriend?
You really like that gun.
What's not to like?
It's kind of creepy.
Not much, I guess.
Exactly.
We'll agree with him so he doesn't shoot us.
Danny noticed your suspicion.
Why does he keep noticing my suspicion?
Walking dead telltale fog.
You and welcome to Mambusha, thank you.
you guys are pretty out in the sticks here hard to find you get many visitors not anymore it's all right when big boss does it though used to get these school kids on tours back before the dead well he does I'm gonna wait for some of it actually well it'll be a good one you know what I mean can I ride this all fixed that should make everyone happy let's go give Klemmer hat what is Larry Scary,
Larry.
Toolbox?
I didn't see that before.
The wisps.
Notice your suspicion.
It's a small toolbox.
That's it!
Chat, notice Minto's cute.
Yeah!
I got that camera too.
Is there a cow in here?
there is oh oh she's so pretty it's okay Clementine you can pet her I want to pet the cow please it's okay go ahead I want to pet the cow oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god you can pet the cow Katya says Mabel could have her baby tonight we'll see Clementine Wait,
what?
The cow is...
What's this thing?
The cow is with child?
A salt lick.
A salt.
Yeah, but don't lick it.
It's gross.
It's like a peanut butter lick.
Did you lick it?
I don't know.
That's my girl.
I wish there was a...
I wish there was a prompt to lick it.
Oh, we can't.
We finally hear the moose!
Moose, what's that?
Me!
Oh.
Salt lick.
Can I lick it?
Have you guys ever tried a salt lick before?
It's just really salty, no?
Me.
Oh.
Empty.
Never seen one IRL.
Me neither, actually.
I had a salt, a rock salt lamp I used to lick more of it.
Those, though, I think I've seen cats like to lick those salt lambs.
That's not good for them.
But cats will also lick them.
Oh.
What is all this?
Oh, I thought that was a person in there.
Looks like a bunch of old dirty clothes.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Spells pretty foul.
Oh.
What happened to the music?
It's like medical stuff.
Now I'm embarrassed.
The saw lamps are dangerous?
Why?
Wait, where'd the music go?
It's kind of spooky.
Feeding trough.
It's a feeding trough.
How bad is it?
oats in it oh yeah mother mother please i crave oats what is that it looks doesn't look like a feed it doesn't look like we're feeding at all though it looks like it's just full of pot like uh wood chips or something
okay we'll talk to them but i also want to see the door
Brother, may I have...
You found it too, huh?
Lee, they're hiding something behind this door.
I got a quick look.
They got boxes of stuff and something metal and sharp.
Don't get paranoid.
It's my job to be paranoid, Lee.
I think so.
I've got my whole family on this farm right now.
How about you?
What about Clem?
Uh...
I'll protect her no matter what.
Yeah.
will look that guy with caution what's his name he locked it up real tight the second we came in I definitely heard a noise back there Lee what my point is we got to know for sure so go find a hammer or something and I'll have this thing off in a second you back me up in case them farmers come running hang on man think this through you smashed the lock then what if it turns out you're wrong after dinner after dinner get a good meal in those kids you're trying to Yeah.
Lose your head, Kenny.
All right, Professor.
What'd you have in mind?
Let me have a look at what we're dealing with first.
Yeah.
Maybe we can pick it.
Oh.
Hey, Lee.
You know how to pick a lock, right?
No.
Why would you say that?
Well, you're, you know, urban?
Oh, you are not seeing what I think you're saying.
Jesus, man, I'm from Florida.
Get it!
Sorry.
Typical Florida, man.
Caddy!
Actually, I learned that picking a lock.
Learning how to lock pick is, like, way easier than it seems.
What?
See those screws?
Instead of breaking the padlock, we can just take off the assembly.
Apparently it's so easy.
Then replace it all again like nothing ever happened.
Alright.
Sounds like you gotta play.
Huge arse!
What are you talking about?
Glad you're putting our Supertask to great use.
Take what it's like.
Can I help you boys find something?
Thank you.
Um, Kenny heard a noise.
Kenny thought he heard a noise.
He's a little jumpy, huh?
Well, you made an excuse.
We're all sure glad his wife is here.
In oblivion, right?
He's a lifesaver, are you?
You got no idea.
You can get a lock.
Hey, uh, do me a favor.
Lock-picking license.
Don't fuck around with this door, okay?
Just, you know, mama gets nervous.
Andrew, I need your help again.
No problem.
Right away, Doc.
Is there dead dad or zombified dad in there?
Distract Andy to get him out of the barn.
Hey, Andy.
How do I distract Andy?
Any thoughts on how to distract Andy?
I don't know, man.
Just look for something outside of the barn.
We need him out of here.
Okay.
Wait, I want to talk to...
look at the cow can i please she looks skinny does she it's normal to me have i missed anything no not really hmm he smells funny in here i smell funny like duty
kids stop laughing about duty kids will be kids kids will be kids How do you like that cow, Clint?
I love that cow.
She's pretty.
Yeah.
I love this cow.
Hey there, Andy.
Hey, Andy.
Yeah.
You got a screwdriver?
For what?
Uh, never mind.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Danny mentioned he needed something.
Did he say what?
Shit, I can't remember now.
Sorry.
All right.
Be right back, guys.
I'm not suspicious at all.
Okay, I'm gonna go lock.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm gonna go get the screwdriver.
I'm gonna go get it myself.
False alarm.
I'm back.
Oopsie.
Oh.
Oops.
Wait.
Oopsie.
Oops.
Oh.
So, how does a woman like yourself run this whole place?
Is he sweet?
Oh, I managed just fine.
Plus, I had my boys to help out.
I couldn't do it without him.
Riz her up, Larry.
Not gonna lie, something about him seems her tied.
Brenda must use this thing for household repairs.
And it probably has a screwdriver in it.
Brenda must use this thing for...
I see the...
There we go.
Multi-tool?
Multi-tool.
That should be handy.
Tag it.
You're just gonna borrow this for a second.
La la la!
Wait, how do I get him?
I could use the generator.
Um...
beep!
I think the generator's off.
I think something...
Damn, this thing is the worst piece of shit.
Something's always tripping the breaker.
Oh, it didn't work?
Oh.
Dang, I thought he would be gone for longer.
My bad.
Not suspicious at all.
Nah.
No, I'm...
very inconspicuous
there's a baby in there careful don't spook her okay
oh the hat hey clementine my hat you found it I knew you'd find it.
You said you would.
Listen, did you give your hat to anyone?
No.
Did you see any strangers around the motor inn who might have taken it?
Why?
It's probably nothing.
Just let me know if you ever see anything like that.
Okay, I will.
Hey, Lee, do you think you'll ever have kids?
Whoa!
I haven't thought about it.
I don't know.
I haven't thought about having kids in a while.
Wow!
Well, thanks for finding my hat.
George, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Do you want to pet the cow with me?
Nah, but you go on ahead.
I guess I do want to pet the cow, actually.
Actually, I would really love to pet the cow.
She looks skinny.
No, please!
Let me pet the cow!
Hey there, Andy.
Yep.
Danny needs something again.
All right, all right.
Be right back, Doc.
This time you'll be gone for A long, long time Alright, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going Go, go, go He didn't need anything the first time Let's do this False alarm, I'm back Ah!
Oh
Okay, good Um, can you help?
I found a multi-tool I picked up something I think could help with the lock all right good to hear Andy keeps coming back I tried distracting Andy but he keeps coming back there's got to be something out there you can mess with to keep him busy for a while okay about those generators yeah I tried I pushed off the I pushed the button okay let's go push the button again you have to kill the Y'all,
the cow will be just fine.
What if I use the tool on the generator?
But I don't want to, like, break it.
I think that's kind of bad, no.
Oh, ah.
There you go.
This doesn't seem good.
I'm going to use the...
Looks like that bell's driving me.
What you're going to call it?
yeah ow damn it I think it's moving fast yeah turn it off and then we wait I'm really just gonna break it but this thing is wait oh my god what the fence he's not gonna notice that the panel is open Oh, fucking thing threw a belt.
Damn it, though.
Ah, son of a fuck.
God, this'll take forever.
Okay.
Yeah, it'll take forever.
Yeah, yeah.
What frack.
Okay.
This doesn't seem so smart.
I don't know.
I think it's because of the thunderstorm incoming that makes me anxious.
what the freak okay
here we go okay
what's that mean dinner mom dad dinner time it's dinner time okay honey let's get that dad dad come on let's eat let's just hate it when a belt inside your generator evaporates come on don't make the children wait I'll make an excuse for you get that thing off say i have bad diarrhea i don't know okay here we go
screws holding it to the door if i can remove a tummy horror yeah exactly they'll never they wouldn't want me inside if my if i was if i was you know pooping
I'm just saying.
It's a good excuse.
I'm scared.
Oh.
Boy, didn't you hear the bell?
Dinner time.
I found the door like that.
Look, I just came in and found the door open like that.
Probably my dear brother.
Hey, was anyone with you just now?
not the doc no she went in the house oh good yeah good i was right i was right cannibals i was right i was right i was right excuse us we had to block the back door after a walker got upstairs don't worry that was a while ago and ain't been back inside since everybody sit down now go get the meal oh this is a delight i could eat a horse where's mark now don't you worry about him i've already brought some food up you just let him rest we're eating mark wash my hands first we're eating mark bathrooms right outside in the hall and be sure to get under your nails you've been walking around in the dirt all day
mark for dinner look at scratches aren't getting through that thing
say say something if you're alive first time mark has been useful we just met him mark marko marky my boy closet door bedroom door
Is that blood?
There's no one sleeping here.
Where the hell is Mark?
Thought Brenda said he was up here resting.
Seems like there's a storm coming.
Oh, I think the storm's already here.
Farm books, cookbooks, nothing out of the ordinary here.
Nobody would have seen Mark be trailed off to the barn.
Wait...
Power cord.
What is this stuff?
Looks like a bunch of medical waste in here.
The food is drugged.
What would dairy farmers need with this kind of stuff?
I guess someone needed some first aid recently.
Musty as hell.
Cannons.
Smart.
They need so much morphine for.
Huh, where is that cord going?
We're just gonna use it.
For the content.
What the hell?
Yeah, don't shut it.
That's fine.
We can take on these guys.
Oh, God.
Hello?
Mark?
Oh.
Oh, he's behind the...
bookshelf?
Oh, hi, Mark!
That's not Mark.
Oh, it is!
Oh, hi, Mark!
Mark!
What the hell happened?
Don't show this to Barry.
Brothers...
What the hell happened to your legs, man?
Don't eat dinner.
Before she eats!
How do I get out of the room?
Go, go, go, go!
No!
It's people!
It's... people!
Yes, Lee.
It's all people in here.
Sit down.
You're so...
You couldn't stop laughing for me!
It's people!
Oh, sit your ass down, Lee.
This lady has made you a meal.
Yeah, Lee.
What's gotten into you?
He just had a start.
They could use some goddamn manners.
You're eating human meat.
That's crazy.
What the hell?
You're scaring the kids, Lee.
You chose to be direct.
Don't indulge him, Lily.
There's always something with this guy.
Mom, I was eating that.
What is going on?
We need to get the kids.
Everyone out of here.
Yeah, we need to get out of here.
We need to go now.
Everything could have turned out okay for you, folks.
He would have died anyway.
We got to think about living.
Settle down, honey.
Growing up in rural Georgia, you're taught not to waste.
It's how I was raised and how I raised my boss.
Now, you got monsters roaming around that do nothing but eat people.
till they eat some more we think we can put that meat to better use and you're all sick sick in the head lee that's not a very nice thing to imply i'm being direct andy is right we go after folks who were gonna die anyways one way or another he's still eating it like y'all lily grab a knife grab a knife Nobody's going anywhere.
We got lots of use for y'all right here
Dang what come on lily what your guns down we're walking out of here my family.
I don't want to die mommy.
I don't want to die.
Everyone everything will be okay.
Yeah we we
Let go Let go of her, you son of a bitch!
Where's our go?
Is that Mark?
Wait, is he a Zombo now, you think?
Mark!
Please!
Someone!
Holy hell!
Oh my god!
Get him while they're distracted!
Oh, they got us.
Well, we're just...
distract them.
Mark!
You couldn't even be useful then to cause a diversion.
I will tear you fuckers apart with my bare hands.
We gotta find another way out of here.
You sad fucking bastards!
At least we can agree with with...
Larry?
Let me... It's Larry.
I had to stop.
It was a person.
eat meat from a person we should just stick with bread i think turn into no no clem it doesn't work like that if he would have stopped us in time come on dad i tried you okay you okay clementine they didn't hurt you did they okay open up lee those psychos have my family and we're stuck in a damn meat locker we gotta get the out of here this goddamn thumb sucker was the one who brought us here you all just shut the up i'm scared don't be it's gonna be okay i'm gonna find us a way out of here i said it was people don't give up we're gonna find a way out of here i said it's people sure honey you keep your eyes open for screws or loose panels anything we can drive away to open a passage out of here okay it's people i'll rip your goddamn heads up and make you swallow them
I'll break that giant door down.
Dad, you can't get...
Yes!
Easy!
Oh, wait.
If he dies, we're stuck in here with a zombie.
Uh-oh, wait.
Wait, not here.
No, Larry.
You have...
Oh, no, no.
He stopped breathing.
I think he's had a heart attack.
Oh, wait.
Oh, but...
Oh, no.
He's not dead.
Oh yes, oh no.
Somebody help me.
He has, this guy screws us over.
If he's dead.
Yeah, he's not dead.
What has to happen, Lee?
Think about it.
You saw that poor bastard at the motel.
He screws us over in his very last final breath.
Truly, truly amber.
But in a few minutes, we're going to be stuck in a locked room with a six foot four 300 pound seriously pissed off dead guy.
Fuck you.
We can bring him back.
Lee!
Good morning later.
I'll try.
Now we have to keep him from coming back.
No!
God damn it, Kenny!
He is not dead!
Uh...
Lily can save him.
Maybe not.
Probably not.
But that man is dead.
You both know what happens next.
Look, Kenny, back at the drugstore when we all thought Duck was bitten.
I gave him the benefit of the doubt.
Maybe we should do the same now.
That was different.
Duck wasn't bitten.
But come on!
We know this guy's not gonna make it.
Remember what Ben said.
Gotta destroy the brain.
Come on, Lee.
You can't be in the middle on this one.
You gotta have my back this time.
God damn it, Lee.
I need you.
Please help me.
Come on, yet.
Wait, how do I?
Come on.
Wait, uh, what is that?
Wait.
What was that?
Wake up.
Help Lily?
Oh, hell no.
Help Kenny.
You're right, Kenny.
Let's get this over.
You fucking monsters!
Both of you!
I don't want to see!
No, no, no!
No!
Please!
Don't do this!
No!
I was drinking.
Don't let go of me!
You're gonna get bit first, ma'am!
No!
Please!
Oh, damn.
With the salt lick.
No!
God help us.
I'm sorry.
Don't you fucking touch me.
Clementine.
You alert.
Clem.
Too much salt will kill you.
That's the name of the...
Lily said he wasn't dead.
He was.
He was dead.
He was dead, Clementine.
But what if he wasn't?
He was.
I promise.
Salt lick to the face.
I know.
Die.
You gotta be strong right now.
I need you to be strong.
Think about something else, something hopeful.
Like what?
Uh, your walkie talk, a safe place.
Some place safe where no monsters can get you.
We're gonna get out, right?
Yeah.
You found a way out?
Uh-huh.
I'm working on it.
Well, at least we don't have to worry about Larry.
Yeah, we murdered him!
Yes!
thing right now getting the fuck out of here we did what we had to oh my gosh I said we would kill him today and we did oh feels good you guys got food now at least hot dog what now you got any ideas the air conditioner yeah there might be a duck behind it oh god what are they doing to catch you duck duck might be behind it was necessary no just wish clem didn't have to witness like this let's face either way he wasn't making it to next chapter he was such a liability lily sorry i'm sorry don't talk to me lee don't fucking talk to me larry would want you to move on larry would have wanted you you think he wanted this of course not you don't know what he wanted you never knew him you never gave him a chance maybe not maybe he didn't give us a chance but i know he loved you
he'd want you to get out of here yeah too soon lee oh he would have wanted you to move on so this is so messed up get away so funny i just need to told you to get the fuck away!
She hates us now.
She hates us.
It's okay.
Oh, wait.
What did I see?
Nothing?
Okay.
Air condition.
There ought to be an air duct behind this unit.
Maybe big enough for one of us to fit through.
I don't know, Lee.
Seems like a long shot.
Does the air conditioner come off?
I think I could take it off.
If I had something to remove the screws.
Ugh.
Yeah, oh, you do still have it.
Of course they took it shit.
Oh, just kidding.
Maybe there's something else we could use.
I've got a rock.
Oh, Clementine, you're the best.
A coin might do the trick.
Do you have a coin?
A coin?
Uh.
If we can remove these screws, the AC should come down easily.
Who had a coin?
Someone earlier was just like, I got a coin that I can...
Oh, it was Larry!
Get away.
Really rub salt in the wound.
Wait, no, I need the coin, Lily.
Why can't you just leave me alone?
I'm sorry, Lily.
But if we're going to get out of here, we need your help.
I need... I need a penny.
I think I may have found a...
way out of here can i borrow some money from you if you had something i could use as a screwdriver a coin or something no what about him look i know this is a terrible time for it but back at the motor inn i'm mugging larry we mentioned something about great robin in other words my father's more useful to you dead than alive if he was alive and had the key to getting us out of here do you think he'd keep it to himself larry would want us What do you want?
My blessing to loot his corpse?
Uh, yeah.
Do what you have to do.
All right, give it to me, Larry.
Oh, boy.
Oh, gosh.
He got him good.
Any idea which pocket he keeps us changing?
A fucking vulture.
I don't want to search his back.
backpocket.
You know what happens when you die.
Nice!
First try, baby.
Okay.
Just gotta remove these screws and get this unit off.
60 cents.
If we can remove these screws, oops.
He's a blockhead.
Penny for your thoughts.
There we go.
Georgia
You got it?
Yeah, one more should do it.
We're working on it.
We're working on it
That was it.
Nice.
Okay, easy There's our way out me nice
Looks like it'll probably lead right into that back room, but it's too small for us to fit through I just do it.
Clementine.
You don't have to do this.
You know you don't have to do this, right?
I know.
I just want to go home.
This will help us get back home.
You're going to be fine.
What do I do when I get out?
See if you can get to the other side of that door and open it.
Clem!
She's venting.
Oh, Clementine!
Okay, did anyone see you?
Oh, my darling!
Oh, my...
There's a man.
Lily, gotta go.
Leave me alone.
Lee, I can see him.
Okay.
It's not safe in here.
For God's sake, Lee.
Didn't even get to say goodbye.
Shh, shh, shh.
Get in here.
I got an idea.
The door is open now.
of heroes stay here take care of lily okay don't go happy birthday thanks for ordering the merch channel thank you i feel like it's been a while since i've seen you thank you
happy birthday
i told you there was something up at this room it's a god damn huge slaughterhouse that's great Crazy.
Oh, okay.
The matter of the meat.
Do I need to remember this?
Yeah, good, good plan.
Good plan.
Ew.
I think I'm gonna be sick.
Mini cattle prod.
Take that too.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, take that too.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
I can only take one or the other.
Oh, there's also a sickle.
What would be best?
Ah.
Hey, watch your step.
That's slippery.
What would be best?
I wonder, I think...
maybe the the cattle from God what's wrong with these people they're crazy bloody tough Jesus this is where they butcher people except Mark Mark got special treatment maybe I shouldn't have sickly in time through there this room would give anybody nightmares I know poor baby poor baby girl Clementine you're so smart okay all right we chose our we chose our weapon of choice this i mean his sickle's kind of awesome though i wonder what's the tastiest cut of meat the thighs so what's the plan yeah what's the plan tell me this is so caught up in his own rant that we could probably sneak right up on him just stick behind me in case anything goes down when we get to the front grab his gun sounds good okay you're ready are you you don't have a weapon yet now let's go let's go stay close oh why am I not sneaking anymore oh
shit damn it do this damn it do that
where's the cow hey what are you doing outside the barn oh my god
What's he doing out there?
I don't know.
I'll keep an eye on him.
Ready to act what I say.
See what he's doing now.
Oh, I know, Mabel.
This is my favorite one too.
When I let one think they can just walk right out.
They never
think.
Some fucker thinks this is a game.
see where he is now okay wait i think he's setting up a trap he did what's he doing he just set up a trap
i don't see anything where the did he go i don't know is he above us again he didn't go past us oh my god wait i'm scared the trap that killed the teeth ah grab the gun nice Oh, no!
My weapon of choice!
Yeah!
Oh!
Kenny!
That's right, Kenny.
It was worth not grabbing the sickle.
So we could see Kenny use it.
You can't have him.
We need the vet.
No!
Can't!
Lee, come on!
Just go.
I won't be far behind.
Zap him.
Zap him!
Oh!
Ah!
you see you understand now don't you you can have me it's how the world works now are you coming on to me get part of yourself so others can live mark never volunteered to be food mark never volunteered to be food I gotta keep it alive if you kill me the meat gets tainted you can't eat it you're already tainted you ain't gonna kill me just like he did killed Jolene.
You don't have any chance.
Choose Danny's fate.
No!
Oops.
Wait, Clem, where did you come from?
No!
He was a bad, bad man.
Gotcha.
Just go.
I'll keep Clementine safe.
Why did she let her out?
We weren't done messing... I mean, we weren't done finishing this guy.
I didn't mean to say messing with him.
Chapter 6 of episode 2.
Okay.
What's the plan?
It's not a zombo, is it?
This is a zombo.
No!
Carly's so awesome.
Is everyone okay?
We heard screams as we were coming up to the house.
They attacked us.
I knew it.
I told you we couldn't trust them.
Shut up, Ben.
How many of them are there?
Two left.
Where?
Larry's dead.
They chopped off Mark's legs and tried to feed them to us.
Shit.
Well, Larry's dead on his own, of course.
You got Duck and Kaja in the house.
Chelsea, thank you so much for the five kisses.
All right, we're coming in to help.
The main gate is too dangerous.
Go around the fence and see if there's a back way in.
I'll keep looking for Kini.
Do you have a weapon?
I don't leave home without it.
Yes, ma'am.
I love her.
I like Carly.
Did he just roll his eyes?
No, no, please, God, no, no!
I got a couple of coins on me.
What happened to my taser?
I'm going to take the boy and check around there.
No, please don't take my boy.
Let go, watch.
Better now.
I don't want to hurt y'all.
Andy?
Danny, is that you?
What's going on out there?
That is me.
Oh, God.
That's really funny.
Come in.
Let me go.
Yeah, it's me.
Get back!
Don't come in here!
Vincent!
Please!
Please don't- You don't want to do this?
Just go away and leave us be!
Oh my god!
Wait, but you need her!
You need her for the cow!
Surprise!
Think about what you do!
It doesn't have to end like this!
Thunder's going crazy.
I'll kill her, Lee!
Just let me go!
No!
No, he's a Zombo!
I knew it would happen.
Stay back!
Don't do anything stupid!
Wait, if she backs up enough, she'll get caught by...
That her girlfriend...
She'll get caught by him.
Come on, back up!
There she goes, there she goes.
A little bit more?
I
don't want to kill you, Lee!
Please don't make this any worse!
You don't have the guts!
Just stop!
Oh, oh, she's gonna get caught by him!
mark mark do do be useful one last time be useful for once in your life and after life please
there we go i said don't move asshole don't you fucking hurt him oh my god let him go god damn it that ain't gonna happen
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Who the fuck do you people think you are?
Look at what you've done.
You brought this on yourself.
No, uh-uh, you did this.
All we wanted was a little gas to keep ourselves safe.
Oh, kill, kill, kill, kill.
Hey!
Somebody, please help me!
Harley!
Oh,
save, it's fine.
We'll redo it.
Lily, help!
This one!
Punch Andy.
Is that all you got, Lee?
I think they all went to the rescue.
Why were they all standing there and nobody was helping?
It's over!
Fuck you!
This dude is dead and mama get out here.
You, you're all fucked.
They're not, I said it's over.
You said, it's over.
Just walk away.
Yeah, walk away, buddy.
Don't you dare walk away from me, Lee.
Why are his eyes so big and puppy dog-like all the sudden?
Come back here and finish this, Lee!
Wait.
Let's just leave.
Three for three?
Get back here and fight me like a man, Lee.
You spared him.
He's alive.
It's kind of even worse that he, uh...
gets to live.
Everyone else is dead.
Oh, no!
Let's go.
Yeah, let's go.
Ew, so crazy.
Zombie had like glowing eyes.
Oh my god, his bomb even!
His bomb is coming out to get him!
That's crazy.
Where's the cow?
Did they get to eat some biscuits?
It's so sad.
Oh.
She mad at me.
Hey, Lee.
I'd say I'm sorry for leaving the motel unattended.
But, you know.
I'm glad you showed up when you did.
Yeah.
If you hadn't taken that shot at Andy, we might not have gotten out of there.
Were they really killing people?
For food?
Uh, yeah.
yeah yeah they were yeah they were that is sick adding the part that clementine ate some like clementine she doesn't know right oh she's not stupid carly so unnecessary though yeah clementine ate it isn't that nasty oh yeah camera i found it while i was looking for the people who shot mark do you want it why don't you keep it sometimes it helps to have something you can Okay.
Oh, Kenny.
How are you doing?
I'll be fine.
Just not as young as I used to be.
Kenny.
Hun, go on ahead and give me and Lee a second.
Kenny!
There's gonna be fallout.
For killing Lily's dad?
Yeah, I would imagine so.
What do you think?
I'm with you.
I'm with you, Kenny.
We'll do what has to be done.
Kenny noticed you're loyal.
Yeah, I'm working with you, Kenny.
I want you to come with us.
I mean it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm with you, Kenny.
I'm with you, Kenny.
That's right.
Lee, did you have to kill those men?
I'm sorry you saw that.
I'm sorry you had to see that, but I only did it to people.
protect us because they tried to hurt us yes reassuring answer okay hey dad what's that noise
sounds like a car oh it does i hear it not more strangers bing bing shut up ben you were a stranger literally like two seconds ago i just met you ben has like been so boring he hasn't done anything except complain oh this is scary oh this is really creepy don't shoot we're here to help don't shoot we're here to help approach the car slowly this is freaky this is pretty scary I saw I got a camera and some coins on me there were like 1500 weapons at the barn and we didn't take a single one?
How did Ben somehow survive all this?
And he looks like clean.
Like his jacket looks so clean.
You know?
Biggies.
Ah.
Oh crap.
What?
Baby you gotta see this.
Oh!
There's a shitload of food and supplies back here.
Let's go?
Is this a trap?
this food could save all of us not all of us oh my god me too I'm also rolling my eyes you don't know if these people are dead if they come back then we're just monsters who came out of the woods and ruined their lives we don't have to take all of this stuff isn't ours finders keepers we don't know don't worry about that duck it's ours now Wait,
I hear footsteps.
Don't worry.
What if it's not?
Well, what if it's not abandoned?
What if it is someone's?
Help!
I think we gotta be a good example to Clementine.
Headlights on.
They haven't been gone long.
That's what I'm thinking, too.
Because, like, the car is still functional.
The battery hasn't died yet.
I think it's...
I'm gonna be a good person we already murdered it can be good now you're right we shouldn't take this what did you get some meal back there the rest of us missed out on we have to take this stuff just take a little why not we've done enough damage already we've done enough damage already what do you mean by that come on Kenny between this and the meat locker you know what it means fine suit yourself the rest of us are taking this stuff oh okay okay what have we got in here look there's more food in that box they have antibiotics what else do oh thank you see if there's any water I think you can take a little like a snack you know why not got it yeah I got it it lee there's a hoodie in here could probably fit clementine
she's good thanks whatever man it's gonna get cold out eventually hey there were some batteries in one of those boxes i thought they might work in your camcorder here you can have some too for your walkie-talkie batteries huh think you can handle those you're not gonna let me live that down,
are you?
No, no, no, we will die.
Lee, you're going to want to see this.
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
What?
Give me the news, doc.
Wait!
Oh.
Ew.
Oh, she's a warrior.
It's not stealing if you need it is what the achievement was called.
She's heavy breathing.
She was spying on it.
Jake, Bart, Linda, and all y'all fucking sickos from the save lots.
They call y'all bandits, but you're fucking raped.
What?
Oh, darling, baby, look at you.
Look at you.
Oh, you need a mama, sweetheart.
We won't let them bandits get you where we...
No.
Okay.
Where's your hat?
I don't know.
Can you help me find it?
Oh, damn.
This has the best mic ever.
I had it a couple days ago.
Wait, so she was...
just crazy and you're safe sitting there acting like things are the way they used to be the dead don't kill their own it's a living you gotta be afraid of the people i used to call friends the people who don't worry little girl bandits got their eye on that dairy as long as they keep getting food from them you'll be safe i promise oh wait well we stopped there wait they're not
Uh-oh.
Oops.
Next time on the locking head.
Megan is done, pal.
Ain't nothing left.
We gotta get the hell out of here.
Lee, I need you to back me up on this.
Is this all you got?
I told you this town is tapped.
Do you have any idea what we had to do to get all that?
We need to leave.
Duck was asking about the farm last night.
Duck.
Not much faces.
Oh, yeah, the RV gets working.
Let's go.
Oh my god, is Duck dead?
Why?
Why do you look like that?
Lily's not doing so good, huh?
Well, we killed her dad.
We did kill her dad.
Maybe people out there got things lined up better.
Better than us at least.
Could be folks who have all this shit figured out.
Do people get mad when they're scared?
Yeah.
Sometimes, yeah, they do.
This is crazy.
I'm the one keeping this group going.
We can sort this all out, alright?
We can sort this out.
Okay, Lily.
I'll tell you what we need to sort out.
We can't let one person fuck this up for everyone else.
Okay, vote Ben out.
Long road ahead.
Episode 3.
Let's see.
Chopped off David's leg.
Yeah, most people chopped it off.
Shot Jolene.
Yeah, wait.
You and 87% of players had Danny shooter, okay?
We did kill Lily's dad.
Helped kill Larry.
You and 31% of players helped kill...
Not enough people are killing Larry.
what does not a majority vote there's
no way he was i mean it would be even worse if we were stuck in there with him no we would have been stuck in there with his zombie body 82 percent of players didn't kill both brothers that's interesting and then you and 44 percent of players didn't steal i don't do no petty theft I do grand larceny.
You enjoy all the killing, don't you?
Natural boar.
I'm not going to steal from a car.
I want to steal the big bucks, baby.
I can't believe that with Larry.
I seriously can't believe that.
And also, I want to kill.
I don't want to steal.
I want to murder.
You wouldn't download a car.
We'll change the 31% to 90%.
Yeah, everybody get this game and get those stats up, baby.
Come on, we can do it.
If we all do it as a team, we can get these numbers high, high, high.
Everybody kill Larry.
Everybody.
We'll take him down.
but seriously i don't okay you can spoil it for me if you've played this but if you don't kill larry does he survive like is she actually able to bring him back i killed larry you're a real one for that vensek no see then what's the point i say i did the right thing kenny still bonks him ah grand theft means so it's kind of illusion of choice oh she is a psychopath i'm just a vengeful ghost you know it's a loyalty check hmm I do I am kind of getting that vibe about the game I think it's more so sometimes who you well no because even I think people said that if you don't if you try to save Doug he still dies and Carly still lives it's just Carly will remember that you did not try to save her first.
So it is not illusion of choice per se, but there are more situations where it's kind of like a loyalty check than actually changing how the entire direction of the game goes.
Wait, you can save Doug?
Uh, uh, wait, but, wait.
Uh, you
don't be that.
you don't be that wait but people said that if i chose dog then it was i you can only have one of them in the group
dog well um maybe we should have a a funeral for him it's fine i like carly i wish it could have been doug or larry easier choice but that's good too because it's all the replay replay value you know that's good too
replay value is always a plus
she's been dead for a week i'm not over it i knew doug for two seconds and i liked him i still have yet to say doug in a playthrough i want to try it you should it should yeah
but uh yeah yeah we did top chapter two we did chapter two this one was crazy i love getting There's always... I figured they were cannibals because that's like such a zombie staple, you know?
That's like such a zombie, like, end of the world trope.
There's always some crazy family that becomes cannibals.
Happens every time.
Called it from the minute I saw them.
Yeah, they totally had cannibal vibes.
like as soon as we were there i was like oh this is a cannibal farm like obviously you can be a little like suspicious of the guys at first as well but i don't know i called the cannibal it's just they just they just had that's the prions it was kind of messed up though seeing mark dead we we met we barely new mark at all we never even got to see him introduced he was just suddenly thrown into our party and then he dies like so fast cannibal core for sure yeah always talking about let's have dinner yeah exactly exactly it's my birthday in two days but i'm busy can i get a quick happy early birthday thunder happy early birthday happy happy birthday happy happy birthday to you Mark felt kind of random.
It felt like a guy that was literally just created to be thrown away.
But it was kind of also messed up seeing him as a zombie at the end.
He died from his...
From getting his legs chopped off.
This craziness.
Hmm.
I did say it was people.
I tried to warn them all.
Choco, taku, thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I tried to warn them.
I said, it's people.
Why did she still take a bite?
Oh, she was hungry.
I understand.
I get it.
Yeah, he was more efficient as a zombie.
How did that happen?
He was finally useful.
Logan, thank you so much for the five good to thank you.
Yeah.
the entire time and then he dies and it's kind of like Larry dies and then becomes useful so we gained one person and lost two neat ducky thank you so much for the five gifted thank you I'm so not used to seeing you guys with these new awesome high profile pictures I'm not used to it at all I don't recognize you guys You're all used Everybody who changed their profile picture You look different I changed back No,
I changed back to Acelot Until the end of Delta at least Some people were wondering If I was going to be playing Delta today Some people were surprised I didn't play it yesterday But yesterday I had some work I needed to do And I had a couple meetings So yeah It wasn't a good day for me yesterday and then i was like well i want to have another full day to play some more so i chose a weekend day sunday ronaldo thank you it's biavas like yes you are couple days of the five gifted thank you guys yeah aren't we so handsome with our pfps i love it i actually love it so much Nito has murderous gremlin intent.
No one is safe under my watch.
Kizo, thank you for the fight, gifted.
Do you like mine?
Yeah, it's cool.
I like the night.
I like it.
Tidikov, thanks for the life, gifted.
So yeah, that's why I'm going to continue more Delta.
on Sunday, even though it makes me sad that I'm not playing right now.
But that's okay.
It also was a long VOD, and I wanted to give some people time to catch up.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Do you actually recognize us?
Yes?
Of course I do.
Why wouldn't I?
oh yeah maybe some newer people don't realize but i'm like i really i i like to remember people's names and profile pictures that's very important to me so when i see someone show up after a while i'm like oh my gosh or if i don't see someone i'm like
Yeah.
I pay attention a little bit.
Sorry, my PFP is clippy.
I like clippy.
I think it's cute.
Thank you.
For the five good.
Hi, Vito.
Hope you're well.
Hi, Cyberfish.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
And Furky.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Do you remember me?
I remember you, Brian.
I remember you.
You can't see me.
I'm invisible.
Corey, man.
Thank you for the pocket today.
I'll remember that.
Okay.
Remember it.
I caved and bought Delta last night.
Oh, the collector's edition.
I bought it, too.
At first, I was just like, if I don't get the terrarium, I don't care.
And then I saw and I was like,
I think I would.
Reminder from your Oshi to change your PFP on the daily.
No!
Don't do it!
Congrats on another episode.
Clear.
Did a little digging choices in this remaster.
It was a different system than the original game.
Oh.
Would explain why it looks like the majority wanted to save Larry.
Interesting.
I remember you.
You remember me?
Are you sure?
Chai Princess, thank you!
Sorry I don't have an actual PFP.
That also...
I remember that too, though.
Like, I remember the big day.
I hope my kamiyoshi is doing well today.
Maximino!
Thank you!
Welcome back.
You sent my PFP.
It is scary.
I don't like tiny faces.
Well, this was fun.
Do you remember the 21st night of September?
Oh my gosh, we're almost there.
We're almost to the 21st night of September.
It has almost been one year since the GG Reckoning.
I can't believe it.
See Alan, thank you so much for the fact it did.
Glad you're playing more of a zombie game.
Rip Dennis though, yeah.
Missed that guy.
Thank you guys for the game today.
I hope you had fun.
I will see you guys when I see you next.
Dwarago, thank you.
I was about to eat, oh wait.
For what it's worth, if someone ran into a room on a sus farm when I was about to eat unknown meat and screamed its people, I would at least pause.
Why is she ate?
She was hungry.
We can't blame.
We cannot blame Clementine.
Phil, thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, I hope you all have a wonderful day, a wonderful night, a wonderful time zone.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Also, also, also, thank you, everybody.
Everybody, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out!
Bye bye!